foreign
we hang out in Nashville in case you
guys forgot and there's always these
famous music people dropped by and see
us that's not happening today instead uh
an extremely famous comedian from
Nashville is dropping by our friend Nate
bargatzi hey Nate how are you good how
are y'all doing great man hey the Amazon
special rocked uh thank you yeah it was
great I uh it's very exciting to be here
Dave we've you know listened to you
obviously my whole life uh with because
my parents would tell me to do stuff
that you tell people to do never I
didn't I wasn't great at it but they had
all the ideas but I I kind of told you
this party I also moved you when I was
like 20 oh it had been 20 years ago uh
you're in a house I think going to a
lake house yeah and I wear this little
lake house down at Estill Springs and I
uh so we were moving you like the
company I worked for we went to your
house and moved you and my one thing you
were very nice everything's great I
don't even you had a TV this was back
when TVs were big yeah they take two
guys to carry one of those yeah but this
TV I don't remember it wasn't it was
like I think what I remember is like a
it wasn't in like a you know if you get
a big wide screen if it was a smaller
one but then you go hey that TV's pretty
heavy and you know I'm 20 you know I'm
like I got it Dave don't worry like this
is
this is what I do as I move TVs and I
picked it up and if you kept concreting
that TV I would believe that it was the
heaviest TV I've ever felt in my life
and then me and my buddy both had a
carrot and I remember not being so big
because our faces were super close to
each other because we were just like
walking like one side on the other side
but I always think about that TV
I'm so glad that Dave Ramsey made an
impression still the heaviest TV I've
ever felt in my life did he offer pizzas
in your fingers I think people want to
know Pizza I don't remember yeah I think
he offered that uh all yeah the my big
ones he goes that TV's heavy you might
need someone to help and I go I got it
Dave don't worry about it don't worry
about me and then you're like oh this is
the heaviest TV I've ever felt in my
life so the uh changing gears the Amazon
special we watched it the other night it
is excellent you did an amazing job
um the uh the The Experience had to be
so much better than the one the the
thing you did during covet that that was
like a root canal wasn't it oh yeah just
outside your bed masculine I couldn't
hear him laugh the first uh so when you
do shows uh if you you say you go do an
hour you know of material or whatever uh
that can also depend on the crowd if
it's gonna be an hour like so if the
crowd if you can't really hear them
laugh and you're having to talk faster
it's like that hour becomes 40 minutes
45 like that much and if the crowd's
Laughing great that hour can be an hour
and 15 minutes and uh the first when we
did the coveted one uh I got done taping
and it was at like I want to say 43
minutes or something and they were like
right when I got off they were like yeah
we do not have it because you taped two
shows when you tape a special and then
you add it on to get like use it and
usually it's all from one show but then
you have maybe a couple jokes you said
better and so when I got done uh they
were like yeah we that was so short and
I was like well I can't hear
anybody laughing you can't tell they had
mask on so you can't even see their face
if they're real or the audience was just
horrendous oh I mean it was painful yeah
it was painful I need this I mean as
somebody who's also on stage obviously
not a comedian but also does a lot of
speaking and stuff it was painful to
think about what you're experiencing but
this one this one and the the setup the
uh production values on this latest one
mm-hmm the the way the audience was
coming around you and the way you were
working them yeah it was really good
well I wanted to after like uh this
place where I taped this one uh the
celebrity theater in Phoenix it's uh one
of my favorite venues uh Carlin taped a
special there Louisa gay tape a special
there and uh it's it was such a cool
like you could see the red car and
special you could see the crowd a lot
because it was just back it was like 70
something when he taped it and so it's
just that's how it was but I wanted to
show a crowd I wanted to show people
having fun because after covet and all
that stuff and say I wanted it was like
you just wanted the crowd to see like
look it's all everybody people are
having fun and people are back out and
people are doing that stuff so it's like
we kind of lit up the crowd a little bit
so you could see them and uh yeah it's
that place is the best as a pastor's kid
when you started talking about the words
that you were allowed to say and not
allowed to say it was absolutely
hilarious I've got to ask you this this
is a money show uh we know that a lot of
money issues in marriage yeah so I'm
just curious your own marriage your
wife's role with money your role with
money like what's that like for you it's
I have no role in it so it's her
uh I don't know I mean I used to have
jokes like I was like if my wife ever
died like I would like I don't know what
bank I would go to like well I don't
know how to get my money out I'd have to
call her mom and ask her to be like you
know what is your maiden name uh uh I
wouldn't know I mean it's I'm
disconnected you know when you grow up
we didn't have money like and so even
though I know is the pressure on my
parents for raising us and saving money
and doing all that stuff I was just
fortunately I guess kind of oblivious I
never really thought about it and I kind
of went in that with comedy and so money
like I've just never
uh thought about it so much it's just
kind of like you're doing what you're
doing like in comedy I would always have
little check marks where I could realize
uh you know I worked at Applebee's I met
my wife at Applebee's on Thompson Lane
and we were yep we worked there together
and so our flare yeah the flare yeah
yeah all the Flair so I remember in
comedy when I got to the point where I
was making just as much as I'd be making
at Applebee's and someone didn't go to
college or anything I was like all right
like I'm making as much as I would make
as you know thirty thousand dollars a
year whatever it is and then you slowly
just have little check marks where you
can just be like all right I'm making
this like I wouldn't make more than this
at whatever job I have uh so but my wife
is the one that does all of it how's it
feel when someone says Grammy nominated
it's crazy that's that's one that you
never I mean because you're like why
would I have to get any of this stuff
like you know as you say uh better than
I deserve uh it's you you don't think I
don't deserve any of this stuff and so
it's and being just from here in Old
Hickory and uh you know who am I like
I'm nobody so it's it's all wild and
it's hard to like take in but it's stuff
I did want you know I have you have your
goal you want to yeah when you think
about it you do want to be as big as you
can be but it's uh yeah when it happens
it's it's pretty surreal how many years
were you at the trade before things
really started to move for you uh I've
done I've done it 20 years and uh so I
was at it I mean you know it's all
gradually I always say you either make
it at 20 or 40 and no one makes it in
the middle so you either get lucky and
get plucked or you have to go grind it
out and uh so it was all kind of
gradually always just kind of moving up
and uh I would say after the Netflix
special the Tennessee kid the stand-ups
in the Tennessee kid was when it really
kind of we took a pretty big leap to
where you go to theaters and people are
there to see you like they know you know
you gotta have new material real you
gotta have all this stuff like they're
there to absolutely see you but I'm not
still getting Amazed by it every day I
was just at the American Century golf
tournament and like just the autographs
and the fact that people know who you
are and you're you know just taking all
these pictures I mean it's it's pretty
were you on the course when Steph hit
the hole in one I was two holes over so
you heard it it was yeah and so we
didn't know who did it but the the roar
was so loud that you're like all right
well someone hey you're like someone's
got that has to be a whole one and then
it's so loud and long then you're like
well I don't know who it is and then
they someone radios over like one of the
volunteers and they're like it was Steph
Curry and you're like well I mean that's
that couldn't have worked out better for
uh NBC and all that it was a very cool
thing to see and to hear it just the
roar yeah wow Nate margacci on
grammy-nominated comedian a neighbor of
ours here in Nashville dropping by to
hang out be sure and check out his new
special on Amazon on hello world and of
course she's on tour right now and how
many cities you're doing uh it's uh all
of them I think uh we go I'm leaving to
Australia Saturday this Saturday oh that
would be in Australia yeah yeah never
been out there doing it doing it with um
doing the show with a little jet lag oh
yeah I think we have a couple days you
lose two days when you go out there I
don't know never knew that tickets at
nateborgatsi.com yep yep there you go
and social at Nate Morgan that's it yeah
thanks for dropping by man
congratulations on all your success
couldn't happen to a better guy uh honor
man honor to be here we always loved you
and uh so it's very cool to be here
we're honored hey Nate markazzi check it
out